THE SENATE BUDGET IN FISCAL
REVIEW SUBCOMMITTEE TO WILL COME
TO ORDER- GOOD AFTERNOON WERE
THE NEW TIME SLOT IN THE
LOCATION BUT- WE'VE GOT A LOT OF
BUDGET WORK TO DO SO THIS WAS
WHAT WAS AVAILABLE. AND AS WE
CONTINUE THEM TO TAKE SOME
PRECAUTIONS TO MANAGE ARE GOING
TO BE NINETEEN OUR PRESS THE
SENATECONTINUES TO WALK IN THE
PARK PUBLIC AND HAS PROVIDED
ACCESS TO BOTH IN PERSON AND
TELECONFERENCE PARTICIPATION FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT. VIGIL'S WISHING
TO PROVIDE PUBLIC COMMENT VIA
TELECONFERENCE ORVIS
PARTICIPATION TOLL FREE NUMBER
AND ACCESS CODE IS POSTED ON OUR
COMMITTEE WEBSITE IT WILL BE
DISPLAYED ON THE SCREEN AND I
WILL ANNOUNCE IT NOW TODAY'S
PARTICIPATION NUMBER IS EIGHT
FOUR FOUR. TWO NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR AND THE ACCESS%
ACCESS CODE IS ONE FOUR ONE ONE
ONE FOUR ONE. AND I WILL
MAINTAIN DECORUM DURING THE
HEARING WHICH IS CUSTOMARY ANY
INDIVIDUAL WHO IS DISRUPTED MAY
BE REMOVED FROM THE REMOTE.
MEETING SERVICE OR HAVE THEIR
CONNECTIONS MUTED WE ARE HOLDING
THE PARK. HERE THE CAP I SAID
MEMBERS OF THE SUBCOMMITTEE- AT
NOT PRESENT IN ROOM ONE ONE TWO-
PLEASE. HEAD TOWARDS THIS ROOMS
WE CAN ESTABLISH A QUORUM AND-
CONTINUE OUR HEARING THOSE
PROVIDING TESTIMONY BEFORE THE
COMMITTEE TODAY ARE ALSO ARE ARE
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY FOR
REMOTE PARTICIPANTS PLEASE MUTE
YOUR PHONE OR COMPUTERS THIS
WILL GREATLY AID IN ELIMINATING
ANY ACOUSTIC FEEDBACK I S. IT
EACH TIME. YOU WHICH TO BE
RECKONED WITH THE CHIEF RAISE
YOUR HAND FEATURED. IN THE
PROGRAM EACH TIME YOU WILL BE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK A POP UP
WINDOW WILL ASK WILL APPEAR AND
ASK IF YOU WOULD LIKE TO BE LIKE
TO ASK YOU P. PLEASE SELECT ON
MUTE BEFORE YOU BEGIN SPEAKING
R. I. T. PERSONNEL WILL. PUT YOU
BACK I MEAN WHEN YOU'RE AT ONCE
RECOGNIZED TO SPEAK PLEASE MAKE
SURE YOU CAN BE SEEN ON THE
SCREEN STATE YOUR NAME AND THEN
YOU'RE READY TO ADDRESS THE
COMMITTEE TO ALLOW THE PUBLIC
ACCESS WITH THE MINUTE WE HAVE
BEEN MADE MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC
TO THE HEARING ROOM TO THE-
REQUIREMENTS. WE'LL BE USING THE
TELEPHONE CONFERENCE SERVICE FOR
THOSE INDIVIDUALS WHO WISH TO
TESTIFY TODAY A PUBLIC COMMENT
WILL BE HEARD AFTER ALL THE
DISCUSSION ITEMS PLEASE NOTE
ISSUE NUMBER FIVE THE SOLAR
EQUIPMENT LIST DIRECT
APPROPRIATIONS WHICH IS A SPRING
FINANCE LETTER- WHAT WILL NOT BE
HEARD WILL BE REMOVED FROM THE
CALENDAR AT THE REQUEST OF- THE
ADMINISTRATION. ONCE WE HAVE A-
AVAILABLE WE WILL BEGIN- LET'S.
TURN TO ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY DISS
ENERGY RESOURCE PROGRAM ACCOUNT
TRAILER BILL LANGUAGE IS TO
SPRING FINANCE LETTER HI ENERGY
COMMISSION. GO AHEAD PLEASE
PERCENT. THANK YOU VERY MUCH- JR
WHITE HOUSE HE MIGHT AUDIO WAS
OKAY IT IS. BUT- EDITORS-
MCCARTY SENATORS THANK YOU VERY
MUCH TRUE BONE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR FOR THE CALIFORNIA
ENERGY COMMISSION THIS ITEM IS
ABOUT THE CDC'S PRIMARY FUNDING
ACCOUNT- BY THE ENERGY RESOURCES
PRO COUNTY WHICH IS IN A
STRUCTURAL DEFICIT. ARE YOU SOME
OF YOU HEARD ABOUT THIS LAST
YEAR. THE REASON IS DEMAND FOR
THE SERVICES OF THE ENERGY
COMMISSION OF INCREASING
STEADILY OVER THE LAST SEVERAL
YEARS INDEED IN THE LAST DECADE.
THE LEGISLATURE STATUS-
APPROVED. OVER SEVENTY NEW
POSITIONS FUNDED BY- AND WE'RE
ORGANIZATION ABOUT SEVEN HUNDRED
SUCH A SUBSTANTIAL INCREASE
SIMULTANEOUSLY THE OPRAH
REVENUES THAT WE RELY ON AS ONE
OF OUR SHE FUNDING SOURCES BY
FAR OUR LARGEST HAVE BEEN
DECLINING. AND WE'D TO
CHARACTERIZE THIS AS ARE BEING
VICTIMS OF OUR OWN SUCCESS
BECAUSE THIS URBAN DECLINE IS
CHIEFLY ATTRIBUTABLE TO TWO
FACTORS THE FIRST IS BEHIND THE
METER- GROWTH- SOLAR IS CHIEF
AMONG THE RESOURCES THAT
CONTRIBUTE TO THAT. AND WE'RE UP
TO TODAY ABOUT TWELVE GIGAWATTS
OF ROOF TOP SOLAR WHICH IS A
REALLY REMARKABLE DEVELOP.
SECOND BECAUSE CALIFORNIA IS-
SUBSTANTIALLY LOWER ON A PER
CAPITA BASIS THAN OTHER STATES
IN THE COUNTRY IN TERMS OF. IN
TERMS OF ELECTRICITY CONSUMPTION
. AND THAT'S IN PART DUE TO THE
BUILDING CODES AND THE CLIENT
CODES THAT THE CALIFORNIA ENERGY
COMMISSION ADOPTS SO WHEN WE-
RATCHET DOWN THE AMOUNT OF
ENERGY THAT CAN BE CONSUMED BY
BUILDINGS THAT THEN DEPRESSES
THE AMOUNT OF ENERGY WE USE
WHICH IS GREAT FOR CALIFORNIA
GREAT FOR CLIMATE CHANGE BUT IT
IT DOES IMPACT OUR REVENUES
SIMILARLY IN THE APPLIANCES I.
JUST GIVING EXAMPLE TELEVISIONS
FROM YEARS AGO WERE IN A
FINANCIAL WE IMPOSED
REQUIREMENTS ON INDUSTRY TO.
DECREASE THE ENERGY CONSUMPTION
FROM THOSE DEVICES AND THE
SAVINGS REMARKABLE EACH TV WE
ESTIMATED WOULD SAVE CONSUMERS
FIFTY FIVE DOLLARS PER YEAR AND
REDUCE ENERGY EXPENDITURES AND
WE HAVE SPENT ON A TEN YEAR
LIFESPAN FOR TELEVISION SO ABOUT
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY DOLLARS IN
SAVINGS WHICH FAR OUTSTRIPS THE
VERY MARGINAL COST ADDITIONAL
COSTS ASSOCIATED WITH PUTTING
THINGS INTO DEVICES THAT REDUCE
THE ENERGY THAT THEY- YOUR- THE
- BEHIND ME. AND THE IF. HAVE
DRAMATICALLY REDUCED ELECTRICITY
CONSUMPTION AND THIS IS WHAT HAS
LED TO OUR STRUCTURAL DEFICIT.
WOULD HAVE KEPT US AFLOAT IS
THAT WE'VE HAD IN OUR BALANCE
THAT WE'VE BEEN USING AS THERE'S
A DELTA BETWEEN WHAT THE
LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATE WHAT WE
STAND AND THEN WHAT WE BRING IN
TRUE- BUT- THEY SPEND DIFFERENT
HEATING IS GOING FOR A WHILE. IN
ADDITION WE'VE BEEN VERY FRUGAL
THE LAST SEVERAL BUDGET CYCLES
WE HAVE REDUCED THE AMOUNT OF-
PRESS ON- BUT BY THIRTY SEVEN
MILLION DOLLARS. OF THAT ABOUT
TWENTY IS FROM FUNDS- FUND
SHIFTED TO OTHER ACCOUNTS AND
SIXTEEN POINT THREE MILLION IS
FROM ACTUAL CITIES WOULD JUST
MADE CUTS AND I'LL GIVE YOU. A
QUICK EXAMPLE WE MOVED TO A NEW
BUILDING AND SUBSTANTIALLY
REDUCE OUR FOOTPRINT AS A
CONSEQUENCE WE ARE SAVING. OVER
ONE MILLION DOLLARS PER YEAR IN
RENT. A SECOND. ISSUE I'VE SITE
IS SOON AFTER THE PANDEMIC HIT
IN MARCH OF TWENTY TWENTY WE
DECIDED IT MADE SENSE TO
ELIMINATE OUR LANDLINE. WE ARE
STAFFED WITH FLIP PHONES
INEXPENSIVELY PHONES ARE VERY
INEXPENSIVE PLANS THAT IS SAVING
US OVER TWO HUNDRED THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR FOR AN AGENCY
OF. ABOUT REAL. QUICKLY- I'M A
YOU HAVE ON YOUR THE SAN. WE
WANT JUST I WANT TO GO THROUGH
VERY BRIEFLY WHAT ARE PROPOSAL
IS IN THE BUDGET. IT WOULD WE
WOULD DO THREE THINGS THE FIRST
IS TO EXTEND THE- SURCHARGE TO.
BEHIND THE METER CONSUMPTION AS
NOTED EARLIER THIS THE ONLY THE
ONLY- CONSUMPTION THAT THE
CHARGES APPLIED AGAINST IS THAT
WHICH IS NEATER. IF WE EXTENDED
TO BY THE METER TYPICALLY SOLAR
THAT WILL GENERATE SIGNIFICANT
REVENUE. AND- BRING BRING THEM
IN LINE WITH EVERYONE ELSE WHO'S
WHO'S BEEN PAYING THAT CHARGE BY
THE WAY THE AMOUNT. ON AVERAGE
PER RATEPAYER IS EIGHTEEN CENTS.
PER MONTH THAT'S HOW MUCH IT
COSTS TO FUND THE ENERGY
COMMISSION TROOP- BUT OBVIOUSLY
IF YOU'RE A VERY LARGE ENERGY
CONSUMER IT CAN COST MORE THAN
THAT BUT- BRIDGES EIGHT. CENTS
PER MONTH PER. METER SECOND PART
THE PROPOSAL IS TO RAISE THE
STATUTORY CAPSULE RIGHT NOW THE
STE THE STATUTE CAPS THE
SURCHARGE EIGHT POINT ZERO ZERO
ZERO THREE- CENTS PER. KILOWATT
HOUR OR THREE TENTHS OF ONE MILL
WE WOULD PROPOSE TO RAISE THAT
CONSISTENT WITH THE REPORT THE
SENATE REQUESTED FROM THE SENATE
OFFICE OFFICE OF RESEARCH TWO
POINT ZERO ZERO ZERO FIVE FIVE.
WHICH THE REPORT NOTED WOULD BE
ABOUT WHERE WE WOULD BE IF WE
HAD INDEXED THIS ONE TO
INFLATION- WHEN ENERGY
COMMISSION. RESET RIGHT NOW WE
ONLY CAN INCREASE AT THAT WOULD
INCREASE THE CAP. THE ENERGY
COMMISSION HAS TO MAKE AN ACTUAL
INCREASE TO THE RATE AND WE HAVE
TO DO IT A PUBLICLY NOTICED
MEANING AND IT'S ONLY ALLOWED-
IN IN THE IN THE MONTH OF
NOVEMBER SO WE WOULD WE'VE DONE
THAT A COUPLE TIMES OVER THE
YEARS. THAT WOULD BE THE
MECHANISM TO DO THAT AND- AND
ANALLY WE WOULD TIE THE STATURE
CAP TO THE CONSUMER PRICE INDEX
SO WE DIDN'T. IT TO INFLATION.
IN CLOSING WE JUST SAY THAT WE
BELIEVE THIS IS AN ACTUAL
INVESTMENT FOR CALIFORNIANS. HE
IT EIGHTEEN CENTS PER MONTH THE
SAVINGS ASSOCIATED WITH THE
BUILDING STANDARDS AND THE
APPLIANCE STANDARDS AND
EVERYBODY'S GOT CHARGERS.
COMPUTERS COMMITTEE. WE RETURN
TO THE RAY PAYERS WHO FUND US
MORE THAN THEY PAY MORE MORE
THAN A PACK SO WE BELIEVE THAT
MAKES OUR INVESTMENT SOUND WHAT
THANK YOU VERY MUCH AND OF
COURSE I WILL BUY QUESTIONS
THANK YOU MISTER BROWN WITH THE
L. A. SHOULD WE- GET RID OF ALL
THE LAND LINES OVER AT THE L.
LEGISLATIVE ANALYSTS OFFICE TO
GIVE YOU A FLIP PHONE AND SAVE
SOME. I NOT SURE A COMMENT ON
PARTICULAR FOLDER RIGHT NOW WILL
. BAKER MAYBE ABOUT THAT THE
BIBLE. I SO BUT WE DO HAVE SOME
ON THE- THE PER ON THE ISSUE OF
THAT DIRECTOR BOW HAND TALK
ABOUT JUST NOW- SOMEONE RUN
THROUGH THAT QUICK I THINK FOR
OFF. I DO WANT TO NOTE THAT WE
DO A THAT THERE CURRENTLY IS A-
ANNUAL DEATH IN THE FUN IN THAT
LEGISLATIVE ACTION BE NEEDED TO
PREVENT INSOLVENCY SOMETIME IN
THE COMING YEARS- HOWEVER WE DO
THINK. THERE ARE TWO IMPORTANT
FACTORS THE LEGISLATURE TO
CONSIDER WHEN EVALUATING JUST
THE MAGNITUDE OF THE PROBLEM AND
WHEN ACTION IS NEEDED- ONE OF
THEM SHORT TERM AND ONE OF THEM
MORE LONG TERM. SO I'M NOT SHORT
TERM SIDE- THE WE WANTED TO KNOW
THAT THE ADMINISTRATION PROJECTS
THAT THE FUND WON'T GO INSOLVENT
UNTIL TWENTY TWENTY FOUR. TWENTY
TWENTY FIVE SO THAT'S A FEW
YEARS NOW SO AS RESULTS.
IMMEDIATE ACTION TO ADDRESS THAT
THE DEFICIT IS NOT ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY- THIS YEAR. IT'S ALSO
WORTH NOTING THAT- THE
ADMINISTRATION. HAS NOT YET
PROVIDED A DETAILED KIND OF FIVE
YEAR OR A PROJECTION OF THE FUND
CONDITION- FIRST SORT OF A FEW
YEARS THE ON THE BUDGET YEAR.
OTHER AS A RESULT THERE
CONTINUES TO BE SOME UNCERTAINTY
ABOUT. WHEN THE FIND EXACTLY
WHAT WOULD GO INSOLVENT- I'M
MORE OF THAT OF LONG TERM-
ISSUES AND KIND OF CONDITION OF
THE FUNDS. THE OTHER ISSUE I
WANTED FLAG IS- AVENUES ARE
PROJECTED TO GROW I'M GOING
FORWARD EVEN BUYING A BY THE
ENERGY COMMISSION AND BOTH ARE
GOING TO MAKE CASE AND HIGH CASE
SCENARIOS YOU CAN SEE THERE'S A
- SHARKS IN YOUR AGENDA- ON PAGE
TWENTY ONE THAT SORT OF. YOU
KNOW SHOWS SOME OF THOSE.
PROJECTIONS IN SORT OF THE
GROWTH OF SALES GOING FORWARD
THIS IS LARGELY DUE TO. A STATE
EFFORTS AROUND ELECTRIFICATION
OF TRANSPORTATION AND BUILDINGS
WHICH IS- TALK ABOUT OF COURSE
IN PREVIOUSHEARINGS- AND SO AS
A RESULT EVEN KIND OF GETTING
OUT SOME OF THE ROADS AND-
DISTRIBUTE GENERATION- THE
GROWTH IN KIND OF. A RETAIL
SALES ARE PROJECTED TO GROW
GOING FORWARD SO THE DEGREE TO
WHICH- A LONG TERM INCREASE IN
THE SURCHARGE RATE IS NEEDED IS
ALSO A BIT UNCLEAR AS REVENUE.
FROM INCREASING SALES COULD AT
LEAST PARTIALLY. ELIMINATE THE
FUNDS I DEFICIT. SO WITHOUT
THOSE KIND OF PIECES IN CONTEXT
IN MIND WE THINK THE LEGISLATURE
HAS SOME DIFFERENT OPTIONS IT
COULD CONSIDER HERE- FIRST YOU
KNOW THE LEGISLATURE COULD
CONSIDER REJECTING THE
ADMINISTRATION'S PROPOSALS THIS
YEAR THE PROPOSAL THIS YEAR. BUT
IT OPS ARE SUPPLEMENTAL
REPORTING LANGUAGE THAT REQUIRES
ADMINISTRATION. DATE ON THE-
NEXT YEAR INCLUDING. THE PROJECT
OF THE LONG. REVENUE IN CAR. AND
THIS COULD BE TO AND- YEARS A
LOT. ADOPTED TYPE OF REQUIREMENT
. AND THAT INFORMATION COULD
ALLOW THE LEGISLATURE K. TO
CONTINUE TO MONITOR THE
CONDITION OF THE FUNDING TAKE
TAKE ACTION AS NECESSARY.
ALTERNATIVELY ALTERNATIVELY IF
THE LEGISLATURE WANTS TO MAKE
CHANGES AS PART OF THIS YEAR'S
BUDGET COULD YOU CONSIDER
ADOPTING CERTAIN ASPECTS OF THE
GOVERNOR'S PROPOSAL BUT
REJECTING OTHERS SO FOR EXAMPLE.
IN OUR VIEW EXTENDING THE
SURCHARGE TO BEHIND THE METER
CONSUMPTION COULD HELP ENSURE.
REVENUES COLLECTED MORE
EQUITABLY ACROSS ALL ENERGY
CONSUMERS AND SO WE THINK. ALSO
CANADA AS ANOTHER PIECE OF THE
PROPOSAL THINK CHINA SURCHARGE
TO INFLATION IS A REASONABLE
STRATEGY TO ENSURE. FUTURE
REVENUES SUFFICIENT TO PAY FOR
GROWTH SPENDING- BASELINE COST
LIKE BROKEN SALARIES AND
BENEFITS FOR CDC STAFF. AND BOTH
OF THESE CASES BUT THE BEHIND
THE METER AND THAT TRYING TO
INFLATION WE THINK THERE'SA
CLEAR POLICY IN FISCAL RATIONALE
FOR MAKING THOSE CHANGES- THE
LEGISLATURE COULD ALSO CONSIDER
OTHER OPTIONS THAT ROUTE REDUCE
URBAN SPENDING SUCH AS- SHIFTING
SOME OF THE COST IS ABOUT ONE
POINT THREE MILLION. IN COSTS
RELATED TO THE EPIC PROGRAM
WHICH COULD BE SHIFTED TO A
DIFFERENT FUND AND- S. ARE A
PART OF THE ISSUE- SO THERE ARE
A- VARIETY OF OTHER.
ALTERNATIVES AND OPTIONS
LEGISLATURE COULD CONSIDER- SO
JUST TO WRAP UP I GUESS OUR
OVERALL COMMENTS WE DO THINK
THERE ARE- OR SOME KIND OF A
QUESTIONS ABOUT THE URGENCY
NEEDED IN THE SHORT TERM AND THE
LONG TERM MAGNITUDE OF THE
PROBLEM- AND THE LEGISLATURE
COULD HAVE A- HAS A FEW
DIFFERENT- ALTERNATE. EXPLORE
YOU KNOW. PACKAGE OR IN SOME
FUTURE YEAR SO IN MY COMMENTS
THERE AND HAPPY TO ANSWER ANY
QUESTIONS YOU QUOTE LET ME ASK
YOU QUESTIONS BECAUSE I DIDN'T.
REALIZED UNTIL IT CAME TO CHAIR
HERE WHETHER MALE IS AND WHAT
THE HUNDREDTH OF A MALE IS ON
THE ELECTRICAL RATES BUT IS THE
STAFF REPORT POINTS OUT YOU
KNOW. ONCE UPON A TIME WE SET
THE RATE AT A- ONE MILL AND THEN
INTO TWENTY YEARS AGO WE GAVE
THEM AUTHORITY TO GO TO. YOU
KNOW TO BILLS OR TO THREE MALES
RIGHT IN IN THE COURSE OF TWENTY
YEARS WE'VE SEEN THAT.
ADJUSTMENT THERE ARE. IF THEY
DON'T THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
RECEIVE A DEFICIT OR REACHING
DEFICIT TOLL TWENTY FOUR TWENTY
FIVE IF WE GAVE THEM THE
AUTHORITY. IS THAT YOU'RE
THINKING THAT THEY WOULD ACT ON
IT BECAUSE THEY KNOW THE EXTENT
OF THE TWICE OVER TWENTY YEAR
PERIOD. YOU SEE WHAT I'M SAYING
IS IT'S A DISTINCTION BETWEEN
GIVING THEM THE AUTHORITY AND
ACTUALLY RAISING RATES. RIGHT
YEAH I MEAN OUR UNDERSTANDING
AND I MEAN I THINK THIS IS-
PROBABLY ALSO QUESTION FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION ARE STANDING IS
THAT THEY WOULD. NOT
NECESSARILY- IMMEDIATELY
INCREASE THE- THE SURCHARGE OF
THIS WHAT KIND OF GIVEN THE
AUTHORITY TO INCREASE THE
SURCHARGE AS THEY SORT OF DEAN.
IT'S NEEDED- GOING FORWARD AND
SO- YOU'LL GET IN SOME OF THE
OTHER. ASPECTS OF THIS TRIP-
TRAILER BILL PROPOSALS SUCH AS
KIND OF ADDING. BEHIND THE
METER- CONSUMPTION TO IT THERE
COULD BE IT COULD BE JUST SORT
OF ADDING THAT CONSUMPTION
ADDRESSES THE ISSUE OR AT LEAST
THE NEXT SEVERAL YEARS AND THEN
THEY MIGHT NOT NEED TO LOOK AT
INCREASING ACTUAL. SURCHARGE
RATE UNTIL UNTIL A LATER DATE
BUT YEAH DEMONSTRATION MORE.
THERE ARE KIND OF GOING FORWARD
IF WERE A PASS YEAH BECAUSE
EVERY HAS THAT THE IDEA OF WHAT
THEY'RE- FISH RESPONSE. AS TO
WHAT'S WE- BUDGET AND- PLUSES
AND HAVING THAT THE WORDY TO DO
THIS LONG RANGE PLANNING OUR-
TRIP TO BOTTOM ARE. YOU WANT TO
TAKE A- LOOK DOWN THAT ENERGY
COMMISSION TEN YEAR PATHANS AND
TELL ME WHAT YOU SEE IF YOU GUYS
HAD THIS AUTHORITY. WELL I CAN
TELL YOU THIS WE ABSOLUTELY IT'S
MY JOB TO BRING TO THE FIVE
ENERGY COMMISSIONERS THE ISSUES-
THAT THEY'RE WORKING ON IT THEY
SEE TO VOTE ON WE WOULD NOT BE
BRINGING. IN BUT CERTAINLY NOT
THIS NOVEMBER IF WE'RE FORTUNATE
ENOUGH TO. HAVE THE GOVERNOR'S
REQUEST GRANTED- WE WOULD LOOK
AT EACH YEAR AND SEE WHERE WE
STAND AND THEN ONLY MAKE
INCREASES IF WE NEED TO DO SO IF
THE- INFLATION ADJUSTED WITH
ENOUGH TO COVER IT IF THE BEHIND
THE METER WAS ENOUGH TO COVER.
MEMBERS CHANGE RATE SO WE CAN
LOWER IT- AND AS I SAY IF YOU
LOOK AT OUR FREE WE'VE BEEN
QUITE EFFECTIVE AT IT- BEING
BEING VERY FRUGAL. OKAY I'M
THOSE ARE ALL THE QUESTIONS THAT
I HAD THE STAFF REPORT IS TO-
KEEP THE MATTER ON HOLD WE MAY
FOLLOW UP WITH A ADDITIONAL
QUESTIONS- AS THEY COME UP BUT
I. THINK BOTH OF YOU FOR THE
PRESENTATION. AND I WILL MOVE TO
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
THIS IS ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY ONE.
IN SUMMER RELIABILITY AND
GENERATION AUDITS THE PUBLIC
SAFETY POWER SHUT OFF OVERSIGHT
THIS IS ALSO SPRING FINANCE
LETTER- P. U. C. GO AHEAD. YES
GOOD AFTERNOON TERRA KASKI
RACHEL PETERSON HERE WITH THE C.
P. U. C. I JUST CHECKING YOU CAN
HEAR ME I CAN GOOD AFTERNOON
GOOD AFTERNOON NICE TO SEE YOU
SENATOR- I AM PLEASED TO BE HERE
AGAIN AND WE HAVE TWO ISSUES ON
YOUR OPEN AGENDA TODAY. AND WILL
START WITH THE- GENERATION
MONITORING AND- PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFF REGULATION-
POSITIONS THAT WERE REQUESTING-
THESE ARE DEEPLY CONNECTED TO
THE ONGOING CONDITIONS OF
DROUGHT AND WILDFIRE AND CLIMATE
CHANGE THAT CALIFORNIA
EXPERIENCING. AND WE HOPE OUR
SMALL SURGICAL EFFECTIVE
PROPOSAL IS TO- PLAY AN
IMPORTANT PART IN THE OVERALL
PICTURE OF KEEPING THE LIGHTS ON
OVER THE SUMMER. AND ENSURING
THAT- PUBLIC SAFETY BAR SET UP
STICKER WITH THE LOWEST LEVEL OF
IMPACT ON CALIFORNIANS AND SO
HERE TO TALK ABOUT THE DETAILS
OF THE PROPOSAL IS OUR DIRECTOR
OF SAFETY AND ENFORCEMENT
DIVISION LEE PALMER. THANK YOU
RACHEL GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS DESPONDENT BUT
CHECK YOU CAN HEAR ME OKAY YES I
CAN MISTER PALMER GO AHEAD.
THANK YOU THAT'S OKAY AFTERNOON
TO CHAIRMAN MEMBERS THANK YOU
AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME TODAY I'M
LEE PALMER DIRECTOR THE SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION WITH THE
CALIFORNIA PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION. IF YOU SEE IS
CURRENTLY REQUESTING SEVEN
PERMANENT POSITIONS TO ADDRESS
AN INCREASED WORKLOAD ASSOCIATED
WITH THE MANAGEMENT BUCKETS
REYES AND IT'S ESTABLISHED A
REALTOR AN ONGOING GENERATION
MONITORING PROGRAM. N. STREET
THING CQC'S ABILITY TO ADDRESS
INCREASING COMPLEXITIES OF BY
YOU WHILE FAR OPERATIONS IN PS.
PS COMPLIANCE OVERSIGHT. DURING
THE SUMMER OF TWENTY. DUE TO
WHITE BLACKOUTS FROM ELECTRIC
SUPPLY SHORTAGES ON THE GRANT
THE GOVERNOR ISSUED AN EMERGENCY
PROCLAMATION FOR SUMMER TWENTY
TWENTY ONE. TO EXPEDITE CLEAN
ENERGY PROJECTS AND RELIEVE
DEMAND ON THE ELECTRIC GRID
DURING EXTREME WEATHER EVENTS.
ADDITIONALLY SINCE TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE INVESTOR OWNED
UTILITIES ARE ALWAYS HAVE
EXPANDED INSTITUTIONALIZED THE
USE OF PS PS. AS A WILDFIRE
MITIGATION MEASURE AND CONDUCTED
ON AVERAGE OF TWENTY THREE PS PS
ABOUT PER YEAR. IN RESPONSE SB
LAUNCHED ELECTRIC GENERATION
MODERATE PROGRAM THE REQUIRED
GENERATORS TO REPORT FORCED FOR
UNPLANNED OUTAGES. THAT REAL
TIME MONITORING AT TWELVE
CRITICAL ELECTRIC GENERATING
FACILITIES. AND COORDINATE WITH
OTHER STATE AGENCIES TO ENSURE
BLACKOUTS EXPERIENCED DURING THE
SUMMER OF TWENTY TWENTY DID NOT
REAR CURRENT TWENTY TWENTY ONE.
ADDITIONALLY THE CPC REVISED ITS
GENERAL ORDER ONE SIXTY SEVEN B.
TO PROVIDE GREATER ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITIES TO THE SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION OVER
REGULATED GENERATION FACILITIES
. GIVEN CLIMATE CHANGE CONTINUE
DROUGHT CONDITIONS AGING
INFRASTRUCTURE AND DESPITE
EFFORTS TO REDUCE THE DURATION
OF THE VANCE PS PS OFFENSE MAY
RATED MAY REMAIN A TOOL FOR THE
ELECTRIC UTILITIES TO MITIGATE
WHAT BARBAROUS. EDITION ONLY
WITH INCREASED ENFORCEMENT
AUTHORITIES GRANTED AND THE
REVISED GENERAL ORDER ONE SIXTY
SEVEN B. THIS REQUEST IS
CRITICAL TO POSITION THE SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION WITH THE
NECESSARY RESOURCES TO CONDUCT
PLAN AUDITS AT THAT ONE HUNDRED
SEVENTY THREE ELECTRIC
GENERATING FACILITIES. IN THE
CQC'S JURISDICTION WHAT GOAL
EVERY FIVE TO SEVEN YEARS BASED
ON A TWENTY FOUR PROJECTED PLAN
AUDITS FOR TWENTY TWENTY TO
TWENTY THREE. THIS ADDITIONAL
STAFF WOULD BE AVAILABLE TO
ADDRESS THAT RECENT EMERGENCE OF
NEW TECHNOLOGY PROJECTS. AND THE
CAPACITY TO WORK TOWARDS
PREVENTING ATTACKS LIKE THE MOSS
LANDING BAD RESTORED OUTAGE AND
ARIZONA BATTERY STORAGE FIRE. IT
IS REQUEST FOR- STAFF AND
RESOURCES IS APPROVED THE SAFETY
ENFORCEMENT DIVISION WE BETTER
POSITIONED TO PROVIDE PROACTIVE
MONITORING OF GENERATION
FACILITIES PRIOR TO THE SUMMER
MONTHS. AND COULD HELP REDUCE
THE NUMBER OF INTERRUPTIONS TO
ELECTRIC SUPPLY AND GENERATION
FACILITIES DURING THE CRITICAL
SUMMER MONTHS. TIME OF SUCH.
FROM EXTREME WHY CONDITIONS YOU
SEE IT ADDITIONALLY APPROVED
THIS REQUEST WHAT EXPAND
CAPACITY TO ADDRESS THE
INCREASED COMPLEXITIES OF
ELECTRIC UTILITY PS PS
COMPLIANCE OVERSIGHT AND
ENFORCEMENT ACTION IN A MORE
TIMELY MANNER. MISTER CHAIRMAN I
HOPE YOU FIND THIS HELPFUL OTHER
FOR TO ADDRESSING ANY QUESTIONS
YOU MAY HAVE AND THANK YOU
AGAIN. I GUESS ONE THE QUESTIONS
BEFORE I GET T. ELLIE- REPORT OR
HOW MANY SAID YOU KNOW PART OF
OUR RELIABILITY IS NECESSARILY
ON IMPORTS THAT WE BRING INTO
THE SYSTEM RIGHT THAT THAT THAT
ENERGY THAT WE- HEAR. THE RICH
RENEWABLE OR NONRENEWABLE THAT
WE GIVE OTHER JURISDICTION TO
COME IN AND SOMETIMES THEY HAVE
CLIMATE- INCIDENCES WHERE
THERE'S WILD FIRE TRAP. HOW DOES
THE P. YOU SEE. I WILL THIS.
WITH THE PEACE SEE WHETHER THE-
PEOPLE HELP WITH THOSE IMPORTED
SOURCES. WELL FROM WITH REGARDS
TO THE IMPORTED SOURCES WE WANT
TO MAKE SURE THAT OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE WITHIN OUR OWN
STATE IS PREPARED TO HANDLE WHAT
IS EVER COMING IN. SO FIRST AND
FOREMOST WE NEED TO MAKE SURE
THEIR OWN INTERNAL GENERATING
FACILITIES AREN'T MEETING THE
MARK AND ARE OPERATING NOT ONLY
TALK TO THEIR RELIABILITY
STANDARDS BUT ALSO THEIR SAFETY
STATE. NO NO I SORT OF I. GUESS
THAT WE DIDN'T HAVE MUCH JURORS
EXTRA JURISDICTION IN UTAH OR IN
WASHINGTON- BELIAU. YOUR
COMMENTS ON THIS REQUEST. WE
DON'T HAVE ANY CONCERN WITH THIS
ROSTER CARE. OKAY LET'S TURN TO
THE FIRST. MISLEAD WILL YOU CALL
THE RULES WE CAN ESTABLISH A
QUORUM. I HAD THAT THAT. SORRY
WE GET YOUR QUESTIONS. HERE.
YEAH. THERE'S THREE MEMBERS
WE'RE A QUORUM IS ESTABLISHED
SENATE MCGUIRE YOU RECOGNIZE
THANK YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
IN APPRECIATED NO ONE TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO THANK YOU TO THE
PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION FOR
THEIR WORK- ESPECIALLY ON ISSUES
OF ACCOUNTABILITY GRATEFUL I
KNOW THIS IS A SEPARATE ISSUE
BUT GRATEFUL FOR THE WORK ON THE
SEVEN TWO HOUR BACKUP UNDER-
PATCHER IT. ENTIRE PUBLIC
UTILITIES IN. IF IT'S ALRIGHT
WITH THE CHAIR WOULD LIKE TO BE
ADDED DISCUSS ON PG&E AN
UNDERGROUND SO. I WANT TO GET A
BETTER UNDERSTANDING ON HOW THE
STAFF MEMBERS ARE GOING TO HOLD
UTILITIES ACCOUNTABLE I'M
ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO THE
ISSUE OF UNDERGROUNDING CELL AS
WE KNOW IT IS IN UNFORTUNATELY
CENTER DOLLY NIGHT TO PERSONALLY
CALIFORNIANS HAVE LITERALLY RUN
FOR THEIR LIVES WHETHER HOMES
BURNED TO ESCAPE FROM UTILITY
BECAUSE WILDFIRES IN YEAR AFTER
YEAR AFTER YEAR. I ESPECIALLY
NORTHERN CALIFORNIA. YOU NEED TO
. I THESE UTILITY WHILE HAVE.
MILLION OF ERIC ACRES OFFOREST
LAND IN BURN DOWN THOUSANDS UPON
THOUSANDS OF HOMES AND
BUSINESSES. AND ALL THE WHILE U.
S. SAN DIEGO GAS AND ELECTRIC
WHO HAVE UNDERGROUND OVER HALF
OF THEIR LINES IN P. JEANNIE IS
UNDERGROUND IN APPROXIMATELY ONE
HUNDRED. MILES A YEAR IF WE'RE
LUCKY. I AND I APPRECIATE THE
NEW CEO WHO HAS SAID THAT IT IS
HER GOAL TO BE ABLE TO
UNDERGROUND TEN THOUSAND MILES
OF DISTRIBUTION LINES IN THE
MOST HIGH FIRE THREAT ZONES BUT
JUST BEING CANDID ABOUT IT. THIS
LEGISLATURE IN THE PUBLI
UTILITIES COMMISSION HAS HEARD
THIS. OVER THE LAST FOUR CEO.
AND NOW THE PUBLIC UTILITIES
COMMISSION IS HERE IN FRONT OF
THIS BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE WANTING
TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE ADDITIONAL
POSITIONS AND I AM PERPLEXED. ON
WHY WE CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE ON
HOLDING ELECTRIC UTILITIES
ACCOUNTABLE FOR UNDERGROUNDING
AND HARDENING OF LINES. AND IN
FACT WE KNOW THAT WE NEED TO GET
THESE TEN THOUSAND MILES
UNDERGROUND- IN THESE HIGH FIRE
THREAT DOWN WE KNOW THAT THERE
IS. A FINANCIAL PATH FOR TO BE
ABLE TO DO THAT POTENTIALLY
BINDING AGAINST WHAT THEY SPEND
ON AN ANNUAL BASIS OF ONE POINT
THREE TO ONE POINT. SEVEN
BILLION DOLLARS IN VEGETATION
MANAGEMENT ANNUALLY AND-
AMORTIZE THAT OVER POTENTIALLY
TWENTY YEARS VERY GOOD TO THE
THIRTY SIX BILLION FORTY BILLION
THAT NEEDED TO BE. TEN THOUSAND
MILES OF LINE BUT I JUST SHARED
MISTER CHAIR MY FRUSTRATION THAT
YEAR AFTER YEAR AFTER YEAR WE
CONTINUE TO HAVE THESE UTILITY
BECAUSE- ACTUALLY. IN SOCAL
EDISON BUT IN PARTICULAR PG&E
TERRITORY. AND IT GOT A SQUIRREL
ON REGULATION SO IF IT'S ALRIGHT
WOULD LIKE TO HAVE SOME OF THE
TIME HE SAID RESPONSE FROM THE
PUBLIC EACH CAN AND HOW THE-
NUMBER WE'VE SEEN IN. IN AND
WILL HAVE A FOLLOW QUESTION OR
TWO. MISS SENATOR ON WHEN I HERE
WERE THE RATES PETERSON I'M
HAPPY TO STEP IN AND BEGIN THE
DIALOGUE. SURE PLEASE I THANK
YOU SENATOR NICE TO SEE YOU
AGAIN RACHEL PETERSON EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR OF THE CDC AND I
DEFINITELY APPRECIATE THE
QUESTIONS- WHAT ALL NOTE IS
THAT- I WOULD RESPECTFULLY
SUBMIT THAT A MEASURE OF
ACCOUNTABILITY HAS IN FACT BEGUN
WITH RESPECT TO P. GENIES
UNDERGROUNDING PROPOSAL WHEN THE
COMPANY ANNOUNCED IT IN TWENTY
TWENTY ONE IT WAS GIVEN GALA
TORY- US THEY MADE THE
ANNOUNCEMENT IN A PRESS
CONFERENCE AND- WITHOUT ANY
INDICATION OF WHEN OR IN WHAT
MANNER THEY ARE GOING TO SUBMIT
A PROPOSAL TO THEIR TWO PRIMARY
REGULATORY AGENCIES. OURSELVES
AND THE OFFICE OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY SINCE THAT
MOMENT SINCE THAT PRESS
CONFERENCE THEY HAVE SINCE
INCLUDED THE UNDERGROUNDING AS A
STRATEGY IN THERE WHILE FOR
MITIGATION PLAN WHICH IS UNDER
REVIEW BY THE SAFETY AND THEN IN
ADDITION HAVE PRESENTED IT TO US
USING STANDARD ICAL OF THE RATE
. AND THAT RICKY OF ADDED VERY
BEGINNING THAT PROPOSED IS NOW
UNDER REVIEW BY BOTH OUR STAFF.
AND THE NUMEROUS INTERVENORS WHO
TYPICALLY PARTICIPATE IN A RAPE
CASE. IF IT'S ALRIGHT TO MADAM
EXECUTOR IN IN IN I KNOW YOU'RE
INHERITING THIS ISSUE SO I AM
GRATEFUL FOR WHAT YOU JUST SAID
MANAGE OCCURRED ACTOR IN PLEASE
DON'T TAKE MY POINT IT. IS
FRUSTRATION WITH YOU BECAUSE I
KNOW THAT ARE COMING ON BOARD.
THE THOMAS FIRE BACK IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN WHICH-
SCORCHED TWENTY ONE THOUSAND
EIGHT R. NINETY THREE ACRES AND
TOOK DOWN ONE THOUSAND SIXTY
THREE STRUCTURES. ARE
DEVASTATING DAMAGE IN TWO
THOUSAND SEVENTEEN THE CAMPFIRE
P. JEANNIE BECAUSE WAS IN TWO
THOUSAND EIGHTEEN THE KING KATE
FIRE PG&E COP TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN SIXTY FIRE PG&E CLASSES
IN JULY TWENTY TWENTY ONE. I SAY
ALL THAT IS WE HAVE KNOWN IT BY
THE WAY THIS IS NOT JUST A P. AT
P. C. ISSUE THE LEGISLATURE HAS
JUST BEEN TO BE CANDID HAS NOT
HAD BEEN AT. IT HOLD THIS
UTILITY ACCOUNTABLE BECAUSE OF
POLITICS AND IT'S INCREDIBLY
FRUSTRATING AND THE ONES THAT
PAY THE PRICE FOR THOSE WHO LIVE
IN OUR SERVICE TERRITORY. BOTH
THE- COMMISSION THE LEGISLATURE
SHOULD HAVE TAKEN A MUCH FIRMER
STANCE THERE'S LEGISLATION
BIPARTISAN LEGISLATION THAT IS
DOING SO NOW I DO WANT TO TAKE A
MOMENT TO SAY THANK YOU TO P.
JEANNIE CEO WHOSE NEW. WHO IS
COMMITTED TO THIS ISSUE THE
NANOSECOND DIRECTOR WE HAVE
KNOWN THAT THIS IS ONE OF THE-
SHINIEST OF SILVER BULLETS IN
OUR- WELL TO BE ABLE TO ADVANCE
THE PUBLIC UTILITY COMMISSION IS
HONEST. WITH YOU AND LONG WITH
THE LEGISLATURE. SO I WANT TO.
HOW THESE NEW POSITIONS GOING TO
HELP EXPERT. GETTING LINES
UNDERGROUND. WELL SENATOR THANK
YOU FOR THE QUESTION THESE NEW
POSITIONS ARE IN FACT INTENDED
TO SURGICALLY ADDRESS A SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT SET OF ISSUES I'M WE
HAVE PROPOSED TO THESE IN ORDER
TO ENSURE THAT WE'RE ALSO
MONITORING AND REGULATING THE
GENERATION FLEET INSIDE
CALIFORNIA. AS WELL AS-
CONTINUALLY NARROWING DOWN AND
REDUCING THE IMPACTS OF THE
UTILITIES USE OF PUBLIC SAFETY
POWER SHUT OFFS- SINCE THOSE ARE
THE PROPOSALS ON THE AGENDA
TODAY I DIDN'T BRING THE STAFF
WHO ARE OVERSEEING AND- STAFFING
THE GENERAL RATE CASE- I'D BE
VERY HAPPY TO ANSWER QUESTIONS
YOU WITH THOSE STAFF THAT YOU
MIGHT HAVE ABOUT HOW THE GENERAL
RATE CASE MIGHT GO. AND HE- BY
P. WILL BE ANALYZE I WILL ONLY
KNOW THE IT IS AN EXPENSE-
WILDFIRE RISK MITIGATION TO. AND
IN THE MORE TOPOGRAPHICALLY- AND
CHALLENGING AREAS OF CALIFORNIA
AS YOU WELL KNOW REPRESENTING
THOSE DISTRICTS- IT'S JUST
COMPLICATED TO UNDERGROUND LINES
BUT NEVER THE LESS WE ARE TAKING
THEIR PROPOSAL WITH ALL
SERIOUSNESS AND VETTING IT AND
STORE THE INTERVENERS IN THAT
PROCEEDING I'D BE VERY HAPPY TO
ANSWER- MORE SPECIFIC FOLLOW UP
QUESTIONS IN THIS WILL BE THE
LAST OF SAVING MINIMUM EXACT
VICTORY AGAIN PLEASE DON'T TAKE
MY POINT QUITE. EIGHT I. THE NEW
THE ROLE IN I KNOW THAT THE
COMMITTED TO THIS I'LL END IT
RIGHT HERE WITH THIS- I KNOW
THAT I AM- ONE TRICK PONY ON
THIS ISSUE. IT IS EXPENSIVE BUT
LET ME TALK ABOUT WHAT'S MORE
EXPENSIVE. IS BURNING DOWN.
THEY'RE IN CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITIES YEAR AFTER YEAR
AFTER YEAR. WE'RE TALKING TENS
OF BILLIONS OF DOLLARS THAT HAVE
BEEN ADVANCED BY INSURANCE
COMPANIES ACROSS THE STATE TO BE
ABLE TO. HELP FOLKS REBUILD
THEIR HOMES AND THEIR LIVES
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT A THIRTY SIX
TO FORTY BILLION DOLLAR
INVESTMENT. BUT I WOULD HOPE IS
THAT THE LEGISLATURE AS WELL AS
THE PUBLIC UTILITIES COMMISSION
COULD PUT TOGETHER A LONG TERM
FINANCIAL PLAN ON HOW THIS CAN
BE- ADVANCED. FUNDED AND
ULTIMATELY EXECUTED SO THAT.
WE'RE IT WE KNOW THAT OUR
COMMITTEES ARE TO BE SAFE 99%
ACCORDING TO FIRE EXPERT
INCLUDING UTILITIES IN SOUTH 99%
OF ALL UTILITY COP WHILE IN
FIRES. I CAN BE STOP BY GETTING
THESE GROUNDS UNDER THESE LINES
UNDERGROUND. IN ONE OF OUR
COACHES IS NUMBER ONE LET'S GET
FEDERAL FINES. FIVE BILLION IS
AVAILABLE RIGHT NOW TO HELP PAY
FOR THESE UNDERGROUNDING NUMBER
TWO. AND FANCYING I TELECOM TO
BE ABLE TO GO INTO TEAM AND- SO-
I LOOK THAT AS ANY DOWN
SPECIFICALLY ON THIS ISSUE. AND
YOU SO MUCH MISTER CHAIR
INTELLIGENCE. ARE YOU READY.
THANK YOU CHAIR IN MADAME
CIRCUIT THANK YOU FOR YOUR
REPORT I HAVEN'T A GENERAL
QUESTION ABOUT GENERATION- WORK
WE'RE GOING TO BE- SOON SHUTTING
DOWN- SAN LUIS OBISPO- DIAVEL
CANYON- AND WE'RE IN A DROUGHT
RIGHT NOW AND WE'RE ALSO- ABOUT
. WHAT IS THE P. C. P. WHAT'S
THE PROJECTIONS OUT FOR ACTUALLY
GENERATION AVAILABLE- FOR
CALIFORNIANS DURING THIS-
SHORTAGE. I SENATOR- NAY C.
THANK YOU RACHEL PETERSON
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR- THERE IS- A
IT ACTUALLY- DIFFERENT TEAM
WORKING ON RELIABILITY ISSUES
AND I'D BE HAPPY TO PROVIDE A
FOLLOW UP- SET OF DOCUMENTS TO
YOUR OFFICE- THERE IS A LARGE
NUMBER OF PEOPLE WORKING ON AND-
INSURING THAT THE LIGHT STATE ON
OVER THE SUMMER. USING EVERY
ELEMENT THAT WE ARE GENERATION
FLEET FLEET PLUS A NUMBER OF
CUSTOMER DRIVEN PROGRAMS JUSTIN
INTEREST. IS A DIFFERENT SET OF
RULES RIGHT I DON'T HAVE EXPERTS
WHO- HAND HEY WE ARE WORKING
CLOSELY WITH OUR AGENCIES THE
CALIFORNIA ISO IN THE ENERGY
COMMISSION ON THAT EFFORT AND
I'M HAPPY TO PROVIDE SOME FOLLOW
UP INFORMATION. THAT WOULD BE
GREAT IF WE COULD HAVE THE
REASON YOU KNOW WE'RE TALKING
ABOUT ELECTRIFYING- THIRTY
MILLION CARS IN CALIFORNIA BY.
THIRTY THIRTY FIVE AND OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE IS- AT BEST RIGHT
NOW WITH A MILLION- ELECTRIC
DVDS ON THE ON THE ROADS OF
CALIFORNIA- A NOT ABLE TO KEEP
UP LAST YEAR THE GOVERNOR ASKED
US NOT TO BE ABLE TO CHARGE OUR
CARS DURING THE DAY WHEN- WE
WERE HAVING PSP TO SELL. DID YOU
SEE WHAT THE LONG TERM- PLAN IS
FOR A GENERATION AND FOR- THE
INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDS FOR-
MEETING THOSE GOALS THAT ARE
BEEN LAWFULLY SET IN CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU. THANK YOU MR A BILL
DONE- MY COLLEAGUES- BOYNTON I
I'D I GUESS I WOULD JUST. I
WOULD ADOPT THE FRUSTRATION- AND
SORT OF CONSISTENT OUTRAGE THAT
EXISTS NOT JUST IN THE NORTH I
WOULD SAY I APPRECIATE MY FRIEND
FROM NORTH TALKING ABOUT THOMAS-
WE'LL SEE. AND ALL THE OTHER
CATASTROPHES WE'VE HAD- IN
EDISON COUNTRY ON THIS FRONT I
JUST. I WANT TO ALIGNED WITH
EVERYTHING HE SAID ABOUT
UNDERGROUNDING- AND SEE IF THERE
HAVE BEEN CHANGES TO THE PROGRAM
THAT PUT PUBLIC SAFETY IS THE
FIRST PRIORITY FOR RULE TWENTY
IMPLEMENTATION BECAUSE RIGHT NOW
IT SOUNDS LIKE. AT LEAST UNDER
EXISTING LAW CAN STILL SORT OF
PURSUE THOSE PROJECTS JUST FOR
AESTHETIC PURPOSES AS WELL. SO
IS THE PC- AT LEAST HAVE ON
THEIR OWN REGULATIONS THE
PRIORITIZATION FRAMEWORK THAT
PUTS. PUBLIC SAFETY IS SORT OF A
WAY TO GET TO THE FRONT OF THAT
LINE WHICH IS WAY TOO LONG OF A
LINE ALREADY BUT- DO YOU DO NOW
. US SENATOR I THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THE QUESTION- NICE TO
SEE YOU AGAIN AS WELL AND I
LITTLE NOTE IS THAT-
MODIFICATION AND CONSIDERATION
OF THE ELEMENTS OF WILL TWENTY
IS AN OPEN ACTIVE PROCEEDING AT
THE CPUC AND SO I CAN'T ACTUALLY
FORECAST THE OUTCOME TO THAT. WE
ARE- THE WAY THEY OPERATE THAT
WE DO RELY GOVERNMENTS TO COME
FORWARD WITH PROJECTS NOW
WHETHER OR NOT WE ARE
CONSIDERING CRITERIA THAT-
INCLUDE SAFETY I CAN'T ACTUALLY
SAY BECAUSE I'M NOT AS FAMILIAR
WITH THE D. THE FOLLOW UP WITH
YOUR OFFICE OKAY. AND THEN- THE
ON THE UNDERGROUNDING ISSUE I
WANTED TO ASK. WE'VE HAD WE'VE
HAD TO PASS A FEW DIFFERENT
BILLS OVER THE YEARS TO. TO TRY
TO NUDGE YOU ALL AS WELL AS THE
I. O. U.'S- TO PURSUE SOME OTHER
TOOLS IN THE TOOL KIT- ON MICRO
GRIDS WE PASSED SB THIRTEEN
THIRTY NINE YEARS AGO AND I. I
UNDERSTAND THAT YOU SEE IS.
STILL YET TO ADOPT- A TERROR FOR
MICROGREENS. I KNOW THERE'S SOME
FUNDING AVAILABLE BUT GIVE A
STATUS UPDATE ON- MORE
DEPLOYMENT OF MICRO GRIDS IN IN
FIRE ZONES DO WE HAVE ANY
DEPLOYED IN ALL OF. SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON TERRITORY OR-
ANYWHERE ELSE. SO SENATOR- AGAIN
I APPRECIATE THE QUESTIONS IT'S
NOT THE A TEAM OF EXPERTS THAT I
BROUGHT WITH US TODAY WE
ACTUALLY HAVE ADOPTED A MICRO
GRIDS TERRACE AND THE
IMPLEMENTATION IS SUBJECT TO-
BOTH THE LOCALITY AND THE
UTILITY BRINGING- PROJECTS
FORWARD TO US PURSUANT TO THAT
TERRORIST WE WILL FOLLOW UP WITH
YOUR OFFICE AS FAR AS WHEN HE
WHETHER ANY ARE PROPOSED OR- AND
PERHAPS A MOVING TOWARDS
IMPLEMENTATION IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA EDISON TERRITORY I
APOLOGIZE I JUST DON'T KNOW THE
DETAILS MYSELF OKAY AND THEN
LAST QUESTION- PASSED THE BILL.
LAST YEAR SB FIVE THIRTY THREE-
WHICH REQUIRES UTILITIES IN
THEIR WILDFIRE MITIGATION PLANS.
TO ACTUALLY QUANTIFY AND
IDENTIFY NOT JUST THE P. S. P.
S. PRONE ZONES BUT SPECIFICALLY
WHAT THE IMPACTS ARE ON
INDIVIDUALS ON MOST THE MOST
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES ON
PEOPLE- SAY WITHOUT. BACKUP
GENERATORS ON FIXED INCOME WHO
ARE ON I. HSS VULNERABLE
SENIORS- WE HAVEN'T SEEN THAT
LEVEL OF DETAIL IN PAST WILDFIRE
MITIGATION PLANS. A DO YOU HAVE
ANY INSIGHT ON THE PC'S PLANS TO
IMPLEMENT SB FIVE THIRTY THREE.
WELL SENATOR THE PRIMARY
RESPONSIBILITY FOR IMPLEMENTING-
WEBER MITIGATION PLANS UNDER
THEIR GUIDELINES AND WITH AN
ASSESSMENT ABOUT PERFORMANCE
LIES WITH A DIFFERENT OFFICE NOW
THE OFFICE OF ENERGY
INFRASTRUCTURE SAFETY. I'M VERY
HAPPY TO- PASS THAT RE QUERY ON
TO DIRECTOR THOMAS JACOBS AND
HER TEAM WITH A REQUEST TO GET
BACK TO YOUR OFFICE ON THEIR
ASSESSMENT- OF THAT IN THE W.
MPS. SO YOU DON'T KNOW WHETHER
WFP'S ARE NOTING THE HUMAN
IMPACTS OF PS PS YEAH. I WOULD
VERY MUCH ASSUMES THAT OF A
STATUTE IS PASSED THAT MY
COLLEAGUES AT ENERGY SAFETY ARE
IMPLEMENTING THE STATUTE BUT
SINCE IT'S ANOTHER AGENCY I'M
JUST SIMPLY NOT ABLE TO ANSWER
THE QUESTION I'M VERY HAPPY TO
PASS THE QUESTION ON. OKAY I
WOULD SAY DON'T JUST PASS ALONG
THE ANSWER TO ME I WOULD I WOULD
ASSUME THAT THIS COMMITTEE WOULD
BE INTERESTED IN THOSE RESPONSES
AS WELL. SO I APPRECIATE YOUR
EFFORTS VERY I GOTTA BE HONEST
UNSATISFYING- YES UNSATISFYING
LEVEL DETAIL BUT- HOPEFULLY
WE'LL GET GET SOME SOME MORE
INSIGHT FOR FOLKS COMING
BECAUSE- PS PS SEASON IS HERE
AND THE DROUGHT IS REAL AND- B.
WE'VE SEEN. COUNTLESS PEOPLE
HARMED- FROM THESE EVENTS WITH
VERY LITTLE RECOURSE THANKS FOR
TAKING. SOME EFFORT AND LOOKING
INTO THIS. RIGHT LET'S. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS ON THE SUMMER
RELIABILITY AND GENERATION AUDIT
SENDS SEVEN POSITIONS- SUGGESTED
BY THE ADMINISTRATION. MISTER
MISTER BROWN YOU DIDN'T HAVE ANY
COMMENTS AT ELIO PASSED RIGHT.
RIGHT NO NO ISSUES WITH PARKER
HI STAFF RECOMMENDATIONS THAT
WE- PUT THIS. WHOLE THIS MATTER
OPEN AT CONVENE DISCUSSIONS WITH
OUR THE PCM. VARIOUS OTHER
ISSUES THAT WERE BROUGHT UP ON
IT LET'S GO TO YOUR-
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGES-
INTERVENOR COMPENSATION PROGRAM
EVIDENTLY THERE'S A BACKLOG. US
SENATOR THANK YOU VERY MUCH- AND
YES WHAT WE'RE AIMING TO ACHIEVE
WITH THIS PROPOSAL BEFORE YOU IS
BOTH THE IN THE FOR AN EFFECTIVE
AND COMPLIANCE INTERVENOR
COMPENSATION PROGRAM AND HERE TO
PRESENTED IS ASSISTANT CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE LAW JUDGE
PATTERSON THANK YOU. HI GOOD
AFTERNOON- SENATORS AND- MISTER
CHAIR MY NAME IS TAX SAID I AM
THE ASSISTANT CHIEF
ADMINISTRATIVE LARGER. AT THE C.
P. C. SO THE- INTERVENOR
COMPENSATION PROGRAM AT THE C.
P. C. COMPENSATES PARTIES BACK
INTERVENES IN FORMAL PROCEEDINGS
BEFORE THE COMMISSION AND THEY
REPRESENT- REPAIR INTEREST
GROUPS INCLUDING LOW INCOME OR
VULNERABLE POPULATIONS- AS WELL
AS ENVIRONMENTAL AND
ENVIRONMENTAL AND SOCIAL
JUSTICE- INTERESTS. AND BE
INTERVIEWED ARE COMPENSATION
PROGRAM IS INTENDED TO
COMPENSATE THESE GROUPS- FOR
THEIR PARTICIPATION AND
REPRESENTATION OF THOSE INTEREST
IN OUR PROCEEDINGS WE ARE
REQUESTING A TOTAL OF. SIX POINT
SEVEN FIVE POSITIONS TWO OF
WHICH ARE LIMITED TERM- IN ORDER
TO ADDRESS THE BACKLOG OF
INTERVENOR COMPENSATION CLAIMS-
IN OUR PROGRAM- OVER THE LAST
SEVERAL YEARS AND THERE HAS
BEEN. AN INCREASED BOTH AND- OUR
OUTREACH EFFORTS AS WELL AS-
CATASTROPHIC WILDFIRE EVENTS AND
A CHANGE TO INTERVENOR
ELIGIBILITY FOR THE PROGRAM AND
ALL OF THOSE HAVE RESULTED IN
ADDITIONAL CLAIMS AND ADDITIONAL
AND INCREASED COMPLEXITY. IN
THESE CLAIMS THAT ARE FILED WITH
THE COMMISSION IN ORDER TO
ADDRESS THE INCREASED WORKLOAD
AND AS WELL AS- TO ADDRESS THE
BACKLOG THAT HAS- BEEN CREATED
OVER THE LAST COUPLE OF YEARS WE
ARE REQUESTING THE POSITIONS SO
THAT WE CAN BOTH- RESOLVE THE-
pTHE BACKLOG WITHIN THE NEXT-
COUPLE FISCAL YEARS. I AM HAPPY
TO ANSWER QUESTIONS- ON ANY OF
THE PROGRAM SPECIFICS AND- WE
ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS THANK YOU.
GROWTH HAS COME IN BECAUSE WE
SEE FROM TWENTY FIFTEEN TWENTY
SIXTEEN DID THIS I COME PROGRAM
HAD THREE PERMANENT POSITION WE
JUST HAVE MORE INTERVENTIONS I
GUESS IS THAT THIS THAT THE UC
WORD YOU HAVE MORE YOU KNOW WE
WERE SEATED INTERVENORS- EITHER
OF THE INTERVENE IN OUR
PROCEEDINGS YES. GOTCHA OUR OF
LEGISLATIVE ANALYST'S OFFICE
MISTER BROWN. NO ISSUES TO RAISE
WITH THIS PROPOSAL MISTER CHAIR
. OKAY- IT'S ALL I THINK IT
LOOKS LIKE WE'RE IT'S- SOME
TEMPORARY SOME PERMANENT YOU
KNOW. IT DID- WHAT RECALL LAW
CLERKS THE TO GO WHERE THERE
ARE- TO GO THROUGH AND PROCESS
ALL THESE THINGS MEMBERS WE HAVE
QUESTIONS. ALL RIGHT WE'RE GOING
TO KEEP THIS MATTER OPEN I DON'T
HAVE ANY MAJOR CONCERNS WITH
THAT I'D APPRECIATE JUDGE YOUR-
PRESENTATION AND- MISS PETERSON
YOU'RE- JACK OF ALL TRADES TODAY
THANK YOU FOR YOUR RESPONSES TO
OUR MEMBERS CONCERNS THAT WILL
CONCLUDE ISSUE NUMBER TWENTY TWO
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME. WE'LL
BE IN TOUCH. OUR MEMBERS FIVE
THAT. CONCLUDES THE- AGENDA I
WILL NOW OPEN UP THE PUBLIC
HEARING OTHER MEMBERS OF THE
PUBLIC HEARING ROOM ONE ONE TWO
SEEING NO MEMBERS ALAS THE
MODERATOR MODERATOR CAN YOU
PLEASE OPEN THEY ARE THE LINES
FOR MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC WE
SHOULD THE COMMENT I WILL SAY TO
THESE PARTICIPATION NUMBER IS.
EIGHT FOUR FOUR NINE ONE SIX
THREE SIX FOUR IN THE ACCESS
NUMBER IS ONE FOUR ONE ONE ONE.
FOURONE MODERATOR. OUR FIRST
JUSTIFIER. THANK YOU IF YOU WISH
TO MAKE A COMMENT PLEASE PRESS
ONE THEN ZERO AT THIS TIME. NINE
TWENTY EIGHT PLEASE GO AHEAD.
HELLO YES GO AHEAD PLEASE YES
ONE TWENTY EIGHT. FIVE YEAR
MEANS JR. YEP WHICH ISSUE ARE
YOU WOULD LIKE TO COMMENT ON.
YEAH I APOLOGIZE IT IN
DREAMLAND- NUMBER YEAH- ITEM
NUMBER TWENTY TWO REGARDING THE
FUNDING FOR STAFF PC TO HANDLE
INTERVENER COUGH CLAIMS THIS IS
A DOCTOR HERNANDEZ ON BEHALF OF
TURN. WE ARE SUPPORTIVE WITH A
COUPLE OF RECOMMENDATIONS. ONE
IS THIS IS BEEN AN ONGOING
PROBLEM WITH HOW THE NONPROFIT
CLAIMS THAT THE LEAVE THERE
ABOUT TWO HUNDRED ON PROFIT
CLAIMS BEYOND THE STATUTORY
DEADLINE OF THIRTY FIVE DAYS.
AND IS CREATING A MAJOR
FINANCIAL PROBLEMS FOR
INTERVENERS INCLUDING CHARTS
TURN ALONE HAS MORE OUT ANY
CLAIMS THAT IT'S ENTIRE ANNUAL
BUDGET. FROM CRANE TWENTY BACK
TWO YEARS WE BELIEVE THAT NUMBER
SHOULD BE MORE SHOULD BE AT HAND. WE SHIFT THE STAFF. JUST
WORKING THE BACKLOG NOW. OUR
STUDENTS POSSIBLE WE WAIT FOR
THE FEW MONTHS HIRE NEW STAFF-
THE INITIAL STAFF MAY BE ABLE TO
HANDLE THE NEW. AND HIGHER
NUMBER OF CLAIMS BUT IT WILL
NOT. TAKE A BIG CHUNK OUT OF THE
BACK LOG IN A SHORT ENOUGH. TIME
TO ALLOW LEADERS TO CONTINUE. TO
PARTICIPATE REMEMBER INTERVENORS
PAY OUT OF POCKET FROM DAY ONE
OF THE PROCEEDING. UNTIL THE END
OF THE PROCEEDINGS WHICH COULD
BE MONTHS OR EVEN YEARS AND HAVE
TO CARRY THIS THAT- FOR A LONG
TIME WHICH IS WHY THE SEVENTY
FIVE DAY DEADLINE. TO PROCESS
THE CLAIM AND WILL CLAIMS BEING
MONTHS AND YEARS PAST THE
DEADLINE- IT IS TOO MUCH OF A
FINANCIAL BURDEN WE OFFER MORE
THAN SIX AND WE OUT FOR
IMMEDIATE ACTION. BY THE
COMMISSION TO SHIFT STAFF TO
ADDRESS THE. BACKLOG AS QUICKLY
AS POSSIBLE. THANK YOU. NEXT
THANK YOU I HAVE NO FURTHER
COMMENT THANK YOU. OKAY WE'LL
CLOSE THE PUBLIC HEARING BRING
AFFECTED DAIS- ALL RIGHT LET'S
GO TO THE VOTE. WE HAVE- THE
ISSUES BEFORE SO THIS IS- I ONCE
AGAIN ISSUE NUMBER FIVE HAS BEEN
REMOVED FROM THE VOTE ONLY
CALDERON REQUESTED THE
ADMINISTRATION WE HAVE ISSUES
NUMBER THREE FOUR SIX THROUGH
ELEVEN AND FOURTEEN THROUGH
NINETEEN. OUR MOTION CENTERED.
THERE'S A MOTION BY SENATOR ALI
MISLEAD PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
AND R. I. COSTI HI HOLLY.
MCGUIRE STERN. MISLI PLEASE
AMOUNTS THE VOTE OF FOUR ZERO
THE VOTE IS FOUR ZERO MATTER SIR
APPROVED AND ISSUES NUMBER ONE
TO TWELVE AND THIRTEEN SENATE
MCGUIRE TO HAVE MOTION THERE'S A
MOTION BY SENATE MCGUIRE MISLI
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL HI KATHY
FIVE- DOLLY. MCGUIRE. THREE ONE
THE VOTE IS THREE ONE THOSE
MATTERS ARE PROOF- THANK YOU
MEMBERS OF THIS WILL CONCLUDE
TODAY'S HEARING- WE HAVE. NEXT
WEEK ON TUESDAYS AND THURSDAYS
PLEASE CATCHER CALENDARS I DON'T
KNOW WHAT ROOM WE'RE GOING TO BE
AND- AT THE TIME OF IF OF. THANK
YOU FOR ALL THE INDIVIDUALS WHO
PARTICIPATE IN THE PUBLIC
TESTIMONY TODAY IF YOU WERE NOT
ABLE TO TESTIFY PLEASE SUBMIT
YOUR COMMENTS OR SUGGESTIONS IN
WRITING TO THE BUDGET FISCAL
REVIEW COMMITTEE OR VISIT OUR
WEBSITE YOUR COMMENTS AND
SUGGESTIONS ARE IMPORTANT TO US
AND WE WANT TO- KLUGER TESTIMONY
THANK YOU AND WE APPRECIATE YOUR
PARTICIPATION. R. ONE ELSE FOR
PATIENTS THAT. WE HAVE CONCLUDED
JENNIFER TODAY'S HEARING THE
SENATE BUDGET FISCAL REVIEW
SUBCOMMITTEE TO CONSIDER.